[Musique]
bonjour patrick karam
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous on
dirait que ce matin sur rtl france la
saturation des services de réanimation
pourrait très prochainement obliger les
soignants distille à faire le tri entre
les malades on va écouter ce qu'ils ont
dit justement ces soignants dans une
tribune du monde où un collectif de neuf
médecins de l'ap-hp demande à l'exécutif
je cite d'assumer devant la société tout
entière sa stratégie face à la troisième
vague regarder nous demandons à
l'exécutif d'assumer devant la société
tout entière sa stratégie face à la
troisième vague en imposant aux
soignants de décider quel patient doit
vivre le gouvernement se
déresponsabilise de façon hypocrite
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
que disent les soignants est ce que
l'exécutif devra assumer sa stratégie
les soignants sont absolument dans leur
rôle quand vous avez un médecin qui vous
dit voilà mes services sont pleins je
suis incapable aujourd'hui au je le
serai je serais incapable de main
d'accueillir de nouveaux patients réa et
bien effectivement il est dans son rôle
de lanceur dallaire et je le
gouvernement est aussi dans son rôle est
aussi dans son rôle de regarder la
problématique plus générale le
gouvernement a les chiffres combien de
patients pourraient être amenés à aller
ailleurs et être transférés ailleurs
quelles mesures à mettre en place et
c'est sur ça qu'on a besoin d'entendre
le gouvernement quelles sont les mesures
que le gouvernement tong pour tenir
cette audi est en train de nous
submerger parce qu'on sait bien que le
confinement et parce que si on parle de
confinement dur
le confinement à des effets
catastrophiques sur le reste de la
société
et seul le gouvernement aujourd'hui à
tous les indicateurs qui pourraient lui
permettre de prendre ces décisions là et
ce faisant évidemment il engage sa
responsabilité
sa responsabilité politique ça va de soi
mais peut-être aussi sa responsabilité
pénale vous vous dites le gouvernement à
tous les indicateurs ils les avaient
bien avancé indicateurs les soignants on
les a entendus il ya déjà plus d'un mois
dire que la saturation allait arriver
n'aurait-il pas fallu prendre des
mesures plus tôt finalement mais celle
ci alors pardon mais cette gestion de la
crise et millimétrée il faut il faut le
remarquer si nous avions été confinés
immédiatement et bientôt le saurions
encore aujourd'hui est ce que vous voyez
que c'est acceptable
écoutez déjà les gens vous avez fait un
reportage assez long sur cette question
de l'acceptabilité des démesures et vous
voyez bien qu'il ya quand même sujet ce
sujet c'est la lassitude et celle des
autres ce sujet c'est d'être capable
aujourd'hui l'imposé un confinement dur
à toute la france et dans toutes les
quartiers et en tout cas en ile de
france dans tous les quartiers d'île de
france et dans tous les secteurs
le vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est
comment paix pour créer des liens ria
valérie pécresse a financé 500 lits en
réanimation est en train de former le
personnel pour ça la question c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement n'augmente pas
le nombre de dix ans rien deuxième
question que l'on doit évidemment posé
sur la table c'est l'attitude des
employeurs on demande du télétravail
on ne manque de trempe loi year met au
maximum leurs salariés en télétravail
ça n'est pas encore le cas aujourd'hui
des chiffres des chiffres que l'on a
montre qu'il ya encore une grande marge
de manoeuvre et l'état lui-même dans un
certain nombre de ces administrations
devraient donner l'exemple
ça n'est pas le cas on se rend compte
aussi dans les transports publics que
les gens continuent à se déplacer nous
étions à 55 60 % il ya deux semaines
aujourd'hui on est encore à 45 100
d'occupation des et de taux d'occupation
des fréquentations des transports toute
la question et savoir à quel moment on
prendra des mesures et à quel moment en
sorte que les gens n'est pas
l'obligation de se déplacer dans les
transports publics que la question que
l'on pose c'est la question juste me
détestent vous avez des problèmes dans
les établissements scolaires
ces problèmes aujourd'hui
ne se pose une vérité un véritable
succès on sait que le variant anglais
qui s'est imposée en france et très
transmissible sur ces gamins sur nos
enfants et le problème c'est qu'on ne
fait pas les tests qui au dans nos
établissements alors jugement justement
on va en parler des écoles faut-il les
fermer la présidente du rassemblement
national s'est prononcée pour
alors que le gouvernement lui ils ne
l'envisagent toujours pas écouté dans la
situation actuelle on ne peut pas faire
autrement que de fermer les écoles
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer le dit lui même à
chaque fois qu'il y aura un cas on
fermera les classes par conséquent
toutes les classes vont fermer
un nouvelle règle aujourd'hui un cas que
vivre dans une classe la classe sera
fermée le carnac de drancy interpelle 60
élèves contaminés ce mois ci et un
parent d'élève qui sont morts depuis le
début de la pandémie même si le lien
n'est pas établi un savut ça donne quand
même à réfléchir non oui vous voyez bien
qu'il ya la preuve de cohérence du
gouvernement évidemment maintenir les
établissements ouverts semble importante
dans la mesure où vous avez des
problématiques de santé publique
derrière les gamins qui doit pouvoir
continuer à manger correctement la
cantine s'instruire ok pas de décrochage
scolaire continue à faire du sport etc
tout ça on le comprend mais ce qu'on ne
comprend pas c'est pourquoi on ne fait
pas de test pourquoi ya pas eu des tests
massif
pourquoi on a pas vacciner les
enseignants pourquoi des mesures n'ont
pas été prises en dépit des mesures
n'ont pas été mises en oeuvre sur la
double job ça fait longtemps que les
syndicats enseignants
ça fait longtemps que la présidence de
région vernement est ce que demande la
présidente de région
c'est de decani l'art entre l'âme les
vacances scolaires faire en sorte de
rapprocher ses vacances solaires
pourquoi le gouvernement ne prend pas
cette mesure
5 compte qu'on avance les vacances
scolaires aux deux au 2 avril au lieu de
le laisser dans quinze jours il faut
prendre des mesures
on peut pas continuer à dire on va tous
laissés ouverts mais on ne prend aucune
autre mesure
il ya d'autres politiques possibles il
faut les mettre en oeuvre alors d'autres
politiques possibles
on va voir ce qui s'est passé à
barcelone justement il y a eu un concert
test vous le voyez un 5000 personnes qui
n'ont absolument pas de mesures
sanitaires à respecter pas de masquer
les gens sont collés les uns contre les
autres
ah pardon oui des masques et c'était 2
on voit à l'image d'où la question alors
c'est un concert test on n'a pas encore
les résultats mais c'est bien la preuve
que des mesures sont possibles pourquoi
par exemple ne pas mettre des masques
ffp2 dans les transports comme le fait
l'allemagne
mais pourquoi effectivement le
gouvernement ne regarde ce type est
possible de faire nous avons aujourd'hui
une jeunesse à vous avec des problèmes
psychiatriques extrêmement important
avec des tentatives et des tentations de
suicide avec la pauvreté la
paupérisation avec d'aider des jeunes
des étudiants n'arrivent pas à manquer
pourquoi ne prend pas toutes n'ont pas
l'étoffé spezza assez efficaces en
contre le virus un oui le ffp2 et
efficace mais on dit aussi que le le
masque chirurgical l'est tout autant
toute la question toute la question est
de savoir aujourd'hui comment on gère
cette pandémie et quelles sont les
mesures ont mis en place vous avez parlé
de barcelone est ce que vous avez en
tête que nous avons tous critiqué
j'étais le premier à le faire le grand
rassemblement qui s'est tenu à la
rentrée en en bretagne et bien il
semblerait puis de celui de coheed la
même chose en martinique vous savez
qu'il ya eu pendant les périodes de
carnaval pendant cinq jours et cinq
nuits un défilé incessant avec des gens
qui n'étaient plus ou moins les masses
on n'a quasiment pas eu de flambée du
coc vide
il ya aujourd'hui ils font ce que les
médecins l'on reconnaisse et d'ailleurs
ils sont très divisés deux ans vous me
dites que les médecins disposent dit qu
il faut re confiné immédiatement de
manière dure non moi c'est passé tout
son temps
vous ouvrez la télé et vous entendez des
voix dissonantes régulièrement sur ces
questions-là problème c'est comment on
fait pour pour décider d'une politique
publique et bien ça le gouvernement doit
être en capacité de prendre des mesures
le pire serait de dire on ne confirme
pas mais on prend aucune mesure
je demande que le gouvernement réponde à
l'appel de valérie pécresse alors denis
dont et vacances scolaires soit vent co2
il faut absolument que le gouvernement
entendre cet appel la voilà on verra ça
lors du conseil de défense mercredi
j'aurais que vous réagissiez aux propos
de d'audrey pulvar la candidate du parti
socialiste aux régionales en île de
france qui ont provoqué des commentaires
indignés à droite et jusque dans la
majorité présidentielle
lorsqu'elle a été interrogée sur les
réunions non mixtes regarder que des
personnes discriminées pour les mêmes
raisons et de la même façon sentent la
nécessité de se réunir entre elles pour
en discuter ça ne me choque pas
profondément s'il se trouve que vient à
cet atelier à destination des personnes
noires et métisses une femme blanche un
homme blanc il n'est pas question de là
où le jeter dehors
en revanche on peut lui demander de se
taire et d'être spectateur ou
spectatrice silencieux qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette réaction faut-il
qu'une femme ou un homme blanc se
taisent lors d'une réunion consacrée à
la discrimination par exemple mais très
franchement pose la question
une part sur l'attitude et la dérive de
l'unef
l'unef syndicat étudiant qui divise
aujourd'hui les étudiants au lieu de les
rassembler alors ils sont aujourd'hui
vraiment épuisé par la crise paupérisée
l'unef ne parle que des sujets société
sociétaux et et veut diviser et pulvar
et ce qu'elle fait on lui pose la
question elle met plusieurs minutes
d'arrêt pont et elle finit par dire ben
voilà on va aller on va les mettre à
part même pardon ça s'appelle pas de la
discrimination ça c'est de la
discrimination
c'est une discrimination violent il va
finir par poser des problèmes à la
france parce qu'à force de considérer
que vous avez deux catégories de
français donc voter les français blancs
de l'autre les autres français qui sont
d'origine étrangère
vous allez finir par créer les
conditions d'une guerre civile
je demande que la gauche et quand vous
dites que l'axé la droite qui a condamné
je pense que vous n'avez pas écouté la
majorité jésus dont politiques de gauche
j'ai vu plusieurs réactions de
responsables politiques de gauche
ils se sont indignés de ça beaucoup
d'organiser
si on retire racistes sont aussi montés
au créneau contre ce propos là parce que
la vérité
qu'est ce qui lie à derrière cette
petite musique c'est la haine du blanc
que portent certaines personnes il faut
se dire cette vérité là il y à cette
espèce de l aider compte qu'on peut
régler entre des blancs et contre des
français et contre la france
en réalité et quand comme contre ce type
p la force de la france son côté
universaliste moi j'appelle toute la
gauche
arrêtez ces vieilles lunes là qui sont
coupables
la gauche a une tradition moralise
universaliste la gauche devrait revenir
à ses valeurs fondamentales
arrêtez de diviser les français il faut
les rassembler nous sommes aujourd'hui
en pleine crise mobile et nous nous
devons nous passer de ce type de deux
postures qui aujourd'hui n'est pas où et
par l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
j'ajoute j'ajoute que je suis d'origine
je suis guadeloupe et reste que je suis
aussi je n'accepte pas que ce genre de
personnes parlent de racisme je
n'accepte pas comme beaucoup comme
l'immense majorité des français
d'origine étrangère ont boudé finissent
sur le terme de racisées ils nous
foutent la paix et qu'ils s'occupent de
leurs repères
merci beaucoup patrick karam je rappelle
que vous êtes vice-président les
républicains de la région ile de france
merci d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions ce matin sur rtl france